[موسيقى]
اكاديمي وباحث وسياسي تركي ينتمي الى
التيار القومي ينحدر من اصل اذربيجاني
وولد عام
1967 في مدينه اغديره التركيه درس اداره
الاعمال في جامعه مرمره عام 89 من القرن
الماضي وحصل على الدكتوراه من روسيا في
العلاقات الدوليه والعلوم السياسيه من
جامعه موسكو عام 2009 عام 2004 اسس مركز
العلاقات الدوليه والتحليل الاستراتيجي
تورك سام ترشح اوغان للبرلمان التركي عن
ولايه اغدير عام 2011 وانتخب نائبا عن
الولايه الوحيده التي فاز فيها انذاك حزب
الحركه القوميه عام 2015 اعلنت ترشحه
لرئاسه حزب الحركه القوميه لكنه طرد من
الحزب غير ان قرار الطردي الغي قضائيا بعد
اشهر قليله في مارس اذار 2017 طرد من
الحزب مجددا مع ثلاثه من نواب الحزب
لدعوتهم
في الاستفتاء على التعديل الدستوري الذي
افضى الى تحول البلاد الى نظام رئاسي
والغاء منصب رئيس الوزراء منذ عام 2017
بقي اوغان مستقلا واعلن ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه
2023 بعد حصوله على التوقعه اللازمه
باعتباره مرشحه تحالف الاجداد الذي يضم
احزابا قوميه يمينيه اهمها حزب النصر من
ابرز وعوده الانتخابيه الغاء النظام
الرئاسي والعمل على اعاده اللاجئين وتعزيز
الجوانب الانتاجيه في الاقتصاد ودعم
الزراعه